better question why wear the uniform of
your own oppressors fight for them die
for them
you got to be part
of the system to change the system nah
you can burn it down
oh
killmonger's a killer oh he's a killer
hi brody your own people mr rudy welcome
back to new rockstars marvel studios
what if episode 6 is what if killmonger
rescue tony stark aka what if 2008's
biggest met and built an empire
that brought the world to its knees
which is also me and philip's origin
story
this is inside marvel our after show for
marvel's what if on disney plus but it's
also going to be our sort of breakdown
of the what if mid-season trailer that
just came out this week i'm eric voss
and folks i got to be honest with you i
am spent from working double shifts for
the past couple weeks we had a
spider-man no way home trailer then
right after that shangqi then right
after that a rick and morty finale then
the marvel zombies episode all these
what-if episodes then we had like within
a few days a matrix resurrections
trailer and a hawkeye trailer i'm
exhausted so empty is doing me a solid
he is going to give me a week off by
handling the easter egg breakdown for
this episode of what if it's going to
come to the channel tomorrow uh but
right now mt and i are just going to
react to this episode empty your
thoughts
dude this episode was uh it's pretty fun
like it's it's cool seeing killmonger
take over wakanda again because that was
his whole mo for ever since he was a
child and he learned that wakanda messed
with his family so like it's just cool
seeing that in different universes he
still has that ammo and he does it in
different ways so i liked it it's cool
yeah it's pretty dark in a lot of ways
in that we follow this tragic hero who
doesn't at least yet get punished for
his uh
his crimes right
it's just kind of like watch there is a
bit of wish fulfillment dark wish
fulfillment and wondering what if uh
killmonger was successful we don't
totally see the um him reaping the
benefits of his succession his literal
success uh but i uh it was fascinating
to like watch him be successful and
hoodwink most of wakanda uh but it
seemed to like end in this open-ended
place it makes me think again i think
we're we're gonna follow up on this
story um but a quick recap so killmonger
saves tony stark from the ten rings in
afghanistan by the way i love that they
just say it's the tin rings not just
like
general terrorists or raz's group or
whatever it's straight up the ten rings
uh i'm i'm surprised tony stark wasn't
like huh ten rings what um but in saving
him killmonger prevents tony stark from
ever building his iron man armor in a
cave with a pocket scraps
and i love how the watcher shows us that
whole history down to tony stark saying
i am iron man and snapping thanos this
forces away an end game but instead we
see tony stark's more immature behavior
he never kind of learned anything from
that whole plato allegory of the cave
that that first iron man was instead he
goes into business with killmonger uh
having killmonger replace obadiah's
stain uh
and he allows killmonger to design his
gundam drones that he designed back in
school and you know that had to have
been a michael b jordan animating one
right like he loves
100 like his his entire costume was
based off of vegeta from dragon ball z
so like yeah now they end up getting
more vibranium from claw in that one
shipyard that we saw in age of ultron
but uh killmonger takes control of his
scenario t'challa shows up and he kills
t'challa very hard to watch i gotta say
of course that is uh but he also kills
rhodey
rhodey uh and then uh tony tries to
avenge rhodey but uh killmogger kills
that drone and kills tony stark as well
wow
you shouldn't have hired a man named
killmonger tony i know jesus sick
killing
um so killmonger it's revealed that he's
kind of the same guy he was in black
panther he is like uh his goal is to
take over wakanda uh and he does this by
leading thunderbolt ross's army of
drones they they're able to like mass
produce these overnight really and then
they he leads him into wakanda but then
he splits off and it kills claw claw
shows him the back door entrance to
wakanda and he takes his body into uh
the country presents it to the royal
family uh and tries to like make nice
with them uh you know showing them his
ancestry uh but then he disconnects the
drones from jarvis uh as they're
invading but then reactivates them i
guess in order to make the wakandans
think that he's good at leading the dora
melange which is awesomely led by queen
ramonda i love i know she's a general i
love that so much because it makes sense
because she would why not why wouldn't
the queen do the general why not yeah uh
and then um so he destroys all the the
drones alongside like okoye but uh sure
he doesn't trust him so even as t'chaka
makes killmonger the next black panther
and he goes to the ancestral uh plane
and uh t'challa's like
this isn't gonna end well for you
shuri and pepper team up to tell
everyone the truth but before they can
the episode ends and once again it ends
right as things are getting interesting
no
we need these to be an hour not 30
minutes
right uh or i don't think i think you
could tell a self-contained story and a
half hour but like
you gotta let your audience know if this
truly is an anthology series or
something that is setting up a narrative
and i think at this point mt
these random endings can't just be left
like this i think there is a plan to
these the fact that we're getting a
clear and clear look at the watcher each
week tells us that each of these stories
are building to something and based on
this and some stuff we saw in the
mid-season sneak peek i think we have a
pretty good idea of what that is going
to be uh but real quick head on over to
newrockstarsmirch.com and check out our
new shengchi designs and our latest
obsession uh great protector shirt as
well as uh this what if shirt oh there's
also a new morris stay in the pocket
shirt
um but if you get either the great
protector shirt or this what if shirt
those are part of our latest obsession
line and you will get the option of
leaving a custom shout out that runs
during the bottom of the screen during
these after shows joshua says what if
thor and hulk weren't off world for the
events of civil war which side would
they choose you know there was an old
episode a big question where we talked
about that like if civil war was redone
um
that's it's a very interesting question
i would say hulk
uh bruce banner's loyalty to tony stark
as a man of science i think uh
especially bruce banner knowing about
the responsibilities of like
how
dangerous super-powered individuals can
be i think you'd totally be on team iron
man whereas thor i feel like as a god he
would trust his own hands more than
those of the state like i don't see the
throne of asgard bending the knee to uh
the u.n or whatever earth-based
government so i think thor would join
team cat
i think i don't know about thor but i i
definitely think that hulk would join
team cap because just him and ross don't
get along at all so i don't know
yeah you're right you're right i think
that is kind of the thing you'd have to
you have to put that behind them and
you're right that would be kind of tough
but uh frankly asks do you think xiang
chi is responsible for katie's
grandfather's death maybe he was the
leader of the iron gang you know a bunch
of people have asked me about this i
think this is a fascinating theory um
but i think that was caused by a lot of
people watching that opening scene
spoiler warning for shengchi i guess
it's not too big of a spoiler it's just
kind of a small thing that happens early
in the movie right
but like i think they had the scene
showing katie's grandmother keeping a
seat open at the table for the
grandfather as a as a statement of the
theme of the movie that it's right uh
kind of a western idea to move on from
the grief of lost loved ones um and uh
it was kind of a warning to chongqi like
oh as you're gonna meet your father this
guy's gonna be very very attached to his
uh deceased wife and he's not gonna be
able to move on so it's gonna be on you
to teach him that it's okay to move on
um but i think for a lot of other people
they're like uh screw that theme stuff i
wanna know who that guy was and assumed
it was set up uh i don't think it was
intended that way by the script uh and i
don't think it's one of these things
where it's so cool it's where in the
future marvel will be like hey remember
this one little thing it's not like the
fun little thing of uh cave in the box
of scraps i just don't see that
character ever coming back especially
since you know the way win woo ends up
in this movie oh yeah and like
definitely especially with uh what we
got in falcon winter soldier with the
winter soldier hanging out with that old
guy like feeling guilt i feel like
that would sort of be copying that in
its weird way it's like oh i'm hanging
out with this
guy's granddaughter that i killed
because like i don't know i just feel
guilty about it but like we just became
friends i don't know
but i don't know if the theory suggests
that chung she's aware of it but if he's
not aware of it that's pretty
coincidental two billion chinese people
in the world and then every dead
patriarch of the family there's only one
dead patriarch that just happens to
happen to me
no
i think it's an interesting theory but
just a theory uh and then roberto asks
what if eric boss is this girl um
we don't know i mean i i to this day i i
still look at you kind of funny because
you know i i don't know sometimes you'll
be acting scrolling i'm like what's
going on what's going on eric
you'll find out in secret invasion
all right mt let's get back to this
episode of what if what is our big
question coming out of this episode well
eric what if the watcher will finally
intervene in the season finale and tie
up every cliffhanger ending that we've
gotten because we've gotten a lot of
cliffhangers over here yeah
you know i think that's where it's got
to be headed now because this episode
more than any before ended with this
clear setup for some other act it's like
we ended in the middle of the episode
and it wasn't like
one of these bleak twilight zone
cliffhanger endings like the zombie
thanos shot or strange supreme it's just
kind of like an uneventful beat of
cherry and pepper going we should we
should chat we should just if we have
good intuition we should probably talk
it wasn't that exciting uh but like so
that's what i'm saying we we're seeing
we're gonna see more of this and i think
the watcher obviously getting closer and
closer to us each week he is spraying
not saying at this point i almost expect
the finale episode empty to be jeffrey
wright's actual face yeah that's the
direction we're going
get him in live action do some mary
poppins live action in the animated
world stuff i want to see that yeah like
we get you keep getting closer and
closer to his face like by the finale i
want to be inside of his nostril
now let's we got to talk about this
mid-season trailer because it hinted
that several of these characters are
coming back so strange supreme we
already know he was going to meet
captain carter there was that weird shot
in the preseason trailer but now in this
mid-season trailer he meets thor who
says zombies great idea
and that's crazy because i think we're
also going to get like a ragnarok-based
episode somewhere in the next couple
weeks so i think those two are gonna
meet uh and then we know chadwick
boseman voiced to childhood for four
episodes in this season and we've seen
three so far so we know there's one more
also in the mid-season trailer there's a
shot of black panther jumping up into
the wakandan throne room it looks like
there's a war going on in the background
that could also be killmonger black
panther since he is the black panther
now we're not really sure but i think
we're gonna see more of this story uh
whatever is the case um so just to recap
the loose threads but before i wasn't
always seen as loose threads i thought
the book was closed we were moving on
from that side of the multiverse but now
it seems like no some of these things
will be coming back so to recap the
zombies episode left uh zombie thanos
with the six stones or five but about to
be six uh there was also zombie scarlet
witch and hulk and and bucky now we
don't really know what happened to them
and then thor rocket and the rest of the
guardians in that zombie side of the
universe are still out there then the dr
strange episode left strange supreme
crying alone as the watcher decided not
to intervene but i think that was the
turning point of this season i think
that was a moment where the watcher's
like huh
maybe i should have intervened
i think that's going to come back i
think he's going to revisit that
decision he's going to open up that case
um there is the avengers murder mystery
episode that left fury about to awaken
steve rogers and the carol danvers
showed up also in this mid-season
trailer stuff there's a lot of like
carol danvers captain marvel action so i
think we're gonna follow up with that
uh the star-lord t'challa episode left
with nice guy thanos hanging out in
wakanda with t'challa the royal family
the wakandans and the ravagers meanwhile
ego found peter quill
and then uh and then the watcher's like
well it's the end of that molt that's
the name of that universe
episode one left captain carter with
nick fury and hawkeye and then pieces of
that same squid monster species that
doctor strange absorbed in episode four
so i believe that this finale of this
sea of this season at least is
shaping up to be things getting so bad
like maybe the multiverse will run out
of viable universes for the watcher
because every one of them people make
bad choices oh my god they end up
falling apart
or maybe empty maybe there could be some
other crisis spreading throughout the
multiverse like the events of loki
unravel a lot of things or like wanda
vision or no way home you know the way
dr strange and peter break everything or
maybe something new in multiverse of
madness like now maybe the elder gods
are pissed off and the watcher in order
to solve that crisis will finally
intervene combining these particular
heroes into one team and maybe by
resurrecting the heroes of who died in
those universes in order to get this job
done and i think the supposed anthology
series has actually been the story of
one hero we're watching the watcher as
he grows as he changes he learns and
he's been showing us all these
characters for a reason because this is
his team of multiversal oddballs that
he's making the case to us
are worthy of attention of worthy of
solving a very particular conflict uh
and i think he needs these particular
people to solve a particular threat and
i think that threat could be the elder
gods could be whoever captain carter
chopped up and doctor strange sucked in
one of them but based off of the
mid-season trailer footage i wonder if
it could be a new incarnation of ultron
as well but no i definitely do think
that those are the two biggest threats
that we could be facing by the end of
this series um especially uh that that
ultron that we haven't seen we do have
like images of this like super like
infinity stoned up vision uh from in
from promo footage or promo material so
we are going to see another type of
vision in the future and that could be
ultron vision because if you remember an
age of ultron ultron made vision to
be his new like physical carbon body um
on the on the planet so yeah i think
that we could see another ultron for
sure uh but you know the with the elder
gods and like these squid creatures that
keep getting teased in the series i
definitely feel like that is just the
general route that marvel studios is
going and what if is the primer for us
to get to know these um you know these
other interdimensional um elder gods
that are just squiddy in nature um so
yeah i definitely do think uh elder gods
for sure yeah i think like
if not the final episode one of the
episodes this season is going to show us
vision ultron uh or like what if ultron
was successful in informing a new form
uh that he was trying to build before
he lost wireless connection
whatever caused it uh
but we're gonna see i think ultron does
deserve a second chance to be shown i
think we've all been asking for more
ultron stories i want to see what kind
of like with killmonger i really want to
see what if ultron was successful
specifically if he had these six
infinity stones where would he go with
that what do you mean
all of life you know
and james spader is just an amazing
voice actor in general so like he would
just deliver an amazing performance
there so more james vader please
so we have like a two general directions
of who the ultimate big bad of the
series could be a very tech based
villain like ultron or a super organic
biological villain from the multiverse
uh elder god squid schumacher whatever
you want to call those things uh i
honestly think what we'll see is the
inciting incident of the finale or one
of these episodes will be the ultron
threat uh but like the post-credits
scene of this series will be something
that sets up multiverse of madness and
will be
either the the squid being or something
beyond it uh and those are either
connected with some other entity but i
think really the direction of the series
is going to set up multiverse of madness
i think that's that's ultimately what
they're setting up well here's an
interesting idea that just popped into
my brain what if they're setting up a
multiversal war scenario because we are
getting these different factions showing
up so we have the zombies we sort of
have you know killmonger's wakandans in
a way but like i don't think that's
gonna be a threat yeah we do have these
elder gods and like i just what if
there's like what if we're getting
different factions that are just growing
now that we're going to see in the
future of the mcu like what if marvel
zombies show up in season two of loki
just causing just multiversal
shenanigans so they should be just cool
to see different players
i think you're right mt and i think
that's what multiverse of madness is
going to be i think it's going to be a
multiversal war i mean cumberbatch has
talked about this being the most
ambitious superhero movie rivaling no
way home
we haven't seen anything for that movie
yet and i think we're gonna start seeing
some post-credits scenes the movie's
coming out march right of 2022 so
we don't need a trailer yet but i think
at some point before the end of the year
we're going to see a trailer for this
movie and it's going to confuse and
delight us
but i think we will have needed to see
what if before i think they're gonna
wait till the end of what if which will
be what by the end of uh september i
think the first week of october is the
final episode i think right around then
let's keep a lookout for a multiverse of
madness trailer because i think this
series is gonna have a post-credits
scene that tells us a lot about what
that movie's gonna be fingers crossed i
can't wait well before we continue with
more questions from this episode uh we
want to thank doordash for sponsoring
this episode if you're ordering doordash
more than twice per month you should
definitely get signed up for dash pass
the easiest way to save money on what
you're already eating dashpas is a
membership that offers unlimited zero
dollar delivery fees from thousands of
restaurants grocery stores and
convenience stores with your membership
you can save an average of four to five
dollars on each order for delivery or
pickup on average dashpass pays for
itself when you order twice a month with
over 18 000 restaurants eligible for
dash pass you may even find a new
favorite restaurant flowers pet supplies
groceries doordash has so much more than
just restaurants whatever you're using
door dash for get those zero dollar
delivery fees with dashpass try a month
of dash pass now and watch your savings
add up start or stop your membership any
time after your free trial ends and if
you're ready to save money on your
doordash orders doordash is offering a
free month for dash pass right now stop
spending money on delivery fees try dash
pass from doordash today for free and
when you've got zero delivery fees
you're free to get more because you can
start your free month today we also want
to thank upstart for sponsoring this
episode if you dread looking at your
credit card statement every month
upstart can help lift that weight off
your shoulders upstart is a fast and
easy way to pay off your debt with a
personal loan all online whether it's
paying off credit cards consolidating
high interest debt or funding personal
expenses over half a million people have
used upstart to get a simple fixed
monthly payment unlike other lenders
upstart looks at more than just your
credit score like your income and your
employment history this means they can
offer smarter rates with trusted
partners with a five-minute online rate
check you can see your rate up front for
loans between one thousand to fifty
thousand dollars you can receive funds
as fast as one business day after
accepting your loan find out how upstart
can lower your monthly payments today
when you go to upstart.com marvel that's
upstart.com marvel don't forget to use
our url to let them know that we sent
you loan amounts we determined based on
your credit income certain other
information provided in your loan
application go to upstart.com marvel and
we want to thank bluetooth for
sponsoring this episode fellas there's
nothing sexier than confidence and
bluetooth can give you the confidence
where it counts blue chew is a unique
online service that delivers the same
active ingredients as viagra and cialis
but in chewable tablets and at a
fraction of the cost you can take them
anytime day or night so you can plan
ahead or be ready whenever an
opportunity arises
the process is simple sign up at
bluechew.com consult with one of their
licensed medical providers and once
you're approved you will receive your
prescription within days and the best
part it's all done online so no visits
to the doctor's office no awkward
conversations no waiting in line at the
pharmacy blue shoe tablets are made in
the usa and prepared and shipped direct
to your door in a discrete package so if
you could benefit from some extra
confidence when it's time to perform
bluetooth can help and we've got a
special deal for our listeners try
bluetooth free when you use our promo
code inside marvel at checkout just pay
the five dollars in shipping that's
bluetooth.com promo code inside marvel
to receive your first month free visit
bluetooth for more details and important
safety information good thank bluetooth
for sponsoring the show all right mt it
seems like you know once again
with this episode of what if there's
always like a uh an implied previous
what if sometimes it's very clear on
screen sometimes it's just like wait no
there was this other
part of the history that set the table
this way in this case what if the true
nexus event of this episode was
killmonger's mission against the ten
rings and what was that mission yeah no
like that seems to be the big like huge
thing that's different from our universe
that killmonger was like infiltrating
the ten rings but yeah no i do wonder
what his actual mission was like within
the ten rings and like you know how he
was trying to infiltrate them from
within because you know ten rings are
themselves a very shady organization
that likes to infiltrate sort of like
hydra in different ways um so like
because the ten rings were so
influential especially during that time
um it would make sense for there to be
like some type of effort to take them
down from within i i think it must be
because i don't think they're saying
that in the original iron man 2008 that
we watched killmonger was actually
already trying to hunt down the ten
rings i don't think that they're
retconning anything i think they're
that's just what happened in this
universe but what i find interesting is
when we just watch chiang chi i haven't
had time to like properly figure out the
exact timeline of those events i just
know when general things are taking
place on screen but like when uh
they met in 1996 right uh when woo and
lee
and then it seemed like sheng chi was
born a couple years after that so maybe
around like 99 and then how old was he
when lee died was he like
seven or eight
so that would make those events around
2006 2007
so i don't know i think like at this
point we're saying when wu has only
recently returned to the ten rings so
you can imagine this is when he's trying
to re-expand his empire and maybe
somewhere in there like after uh
after
no because the leader of the iron gang
would still be alive uh shengshi didn't
go kill him until he was 18. i think so
that would happen later
i think that when wu could have even
though he retired to raise his kids he
could have just had control over the 10
rings and just let his operation just go
like on its own while he was just like
i'm not going to be in charge killing me
like he's just on the board of directors
sitting there yeah i was just like i've
retired like i'm here on the side you
guys do your thing i've i'm a vote
empire
yeah i'm a shareholder still a majority
shareholder
um i think he i think he'd put it away i
think he was done with it and maybe
that's why the empire started to fall
apart and the iron gang was able to find
the family in the compound and i think
that's why things seem to be pretty
decentralized like it was interesting
how raza's group
they would still call it the tin rings
they were you could argue they were
appropriating it and i think they were
able to do that because when wu was
still kind of rebuilding his network and
his empire
so i think that's why i think that's at
least a decent answer why um but i would
say killmonger's mission might have been
related to hey this guy who we thought
was retired has now come back uh so we
need you to infiltrate these different
militant groups that are all using the
same iconography around the world and
see what you can learn i think that's
what his mission was i don't know why he
wasn't assigned that
in the live-action mcu
um because
i just find the character of killmonger
to have a fascinating journey that i
feel like this
this uh episode and the black panther
film they just didn't really have time
to go into that but like he's a
decorated
military officer he's a uh he has all
these kills you know but he's also like
a genius do you say mit student yeah he
was from mit
yeah so like
i
i love his story he'd be like in his 20s
and for him to have all those medals all
those accomplishments and the guys like
in his mid-20s it's like whoa this guy
is like a superhuman for sure yeah dude
is like black zemo on steroids man like
that man is a mastermind like he's one
of like the few like masterminds that we
have in the mcu and i love him for that
reason yeah i i want to see him like uh
that's why it was fun to see him succeed
um but like the way he was just like
killing people off like i wanted him to
have like a more loki-esque master plan
you know for everything that really
caught us by surprise maybe it's just
because we saw him in the black panther
film we knew what his uh his goals were
but uh the fact that he was it seems
kind of like rush that he would kill off
black panther that way and that he would
kill off rhodey it seemed kind of like
what the like i don't know
what like a steven seagal action movie
villain
i don't know i think i think killmonger
can find more interesting ways to use
these people than just oh hell yeah all
right another question i want to ask you
mt
one of the kind of implications of this
episode was what if the world might have
actually been a safer place if tony
stark never became iron man now in this
case he meets killmonger not necessarily
a safer place at all but had tony stark
been able to survive uh
afghanistan if those ieds didn't you
know blow up the convoy uh and if he
wasn't attacked did the existence of
iron man create a chain of events that
made the mcu
what it is no i like that you bring that
up because like i do love to bring up
visions quote from civil war talking
specifically about the introduction of
iron man being this like factor that
sort of just made everything crazier um
in the mcu i think that the world might
i don't know if it would have been safer
but like a lot of you know crazy things
like ultron and you know like iron
monger whiplash in like the
peter parker's
rogue gallery and uh freaking right
everyone all of spider-man's villains
are people who use stark tech i think
the one argument of stark making things
safer was in the first avengers film
right he's right he's key in the
avengers lineup coming together and he's
the one who flies the nuke through the
wormhole without stark new york probably
would have been nuked because yeah you
could have had other avengers on that
lineup maybe you could say captain
marvel was in there instead or some
other uh or like you know some
in the peggy carter reality if like they
howard stark perfected the iron man
armor someone else
uh who's equally noble but i don't know
i think there is an avengers lineup who
could have fought off loki in 2012 but
it was in that moment by nuking the
chicharri fleet that's what got thanos
attention that's what put earth on their
radar there was that line from thor
where he said the tesseract was a signal
to other realms that earth is ready for
a higher form of war as you said no
ultron
civil war would not have been what it
was arguably you could say tony stark's
obsession with putting a suit of armor
around the world is what released more
and more weapons at least the way the
mcu has told these stories i'm not
saying philosophically that's going to
be the case without tony stark it's a
far more boring cinematic universe i'll
say that because with mistakes with
conflict come action and uh
and catharsis and change and i think
it's a better obviously better off but
for the for the people walking around
the civilians of this world i don't
think we want to see
uh
tony stark centuries flying around
knocking our houses down not ideal
[Laughter]
skynet's no good now empty before this
episode started we were talking about uh
we just talked about the character of
killmonger this episode and
how like he is supposed to be this i
guess a tragic hero right he's a hero
who who does bad things are we still
rooting for him uh and we never really
see him punished for that and that's
kind of something that's been different
from all over what while all other
what-if episodes is most episodes really
punish the characters dr strange does a
lot of bad stuff in his episode but ends
the episode in this kind of tortuous
hell uh this marvel zombies episode as
jokey as they all are they all seem to
be pretty punished by the end of that
episode uh christine uh didn't uh tip
one time and that's why she died
multiple times yeah yeah yeah
so uh we're talking about michael b
jordan's performance of uh of this
character of killmonger and there is
something interesting with these actors
from the movies
doing these animated versions of the
characters i think michael b jordan's
such a physical actor and he's such like
a powerful presence on screen a bit of
it got lost in some of his animation and
specifically there was when he said
wakanda forever
or wakanda forever it doesn't sound it
just felt
weak it felt wrong
i have a theory real quick that maybe
that might have been intentional because
i know michael b jordan is a great actor
and i wonder if they had him read it
that way in order to show that his heart
was not really in saving wakanda that he
knows deep down
he doesn't care about the
the state of wakanda he cares about
helping his brothers all over the world
so by he can't say wakanda forever with
the gusto that all the other characters
say it because it's in his mind not
really
what his priority is yeah that would
make a lot of sense because he doesn't
give a damn about wakanda like he's like
who cares about wakanda i don't care if
wakanda like ended tomorrow who gives a
like it's it wasn't really wakanda
forever for him it was wakanda until my
needs are met sort of right hillbogger
so like yeah i would probably phone it
in too if i had this master plan and
like you know like all right now i gotta
do the battle all right wakanda forever
i guess
yeah my hope for season two going
looking forward on the series right i
hope that like the actors that they're
able to get because ultimately it's so
exciting that they're able to bring
these actors back in these roles and
take them in completely different
hypothetical directions i love that i
think we're both very grateful for that
but uh i hope that somewhere between the
animators and the writing team and the
show runners the directors can work with
these actors and show them what it's
going to look like in the final product
and be like look
it's you have to do a bit more as a
voice actor for animation you have to do
far more characterization
in your lines than you would normally do
if it was your face on screen because
actors are used to using all tools in
the tool chest right just little ticks
on they're used to playing small right
because if you play cartoony and big
over the top on screen your face is an
imax size people will be like whoa tone
it down but
in uh an animation you have to dial up
your vocal delivery a bit more than you
would but it's still a difficult balance
because you don't want to be stupid and
cartoony
even though it is animated uh you don't
want to be too silly
um but you do have to like you have to
do more storytelling with your delivery
and i hope that they can continue to
build on that in season two well we'll
leave it there for this episode of
inside marvel mt and i will be back next
wednesday with our what if episode 7
reaction again empty i'm sorry we've
delayed you so much you got to get back
to working on the breakdown and i very
much appreciate you uh taking that off
my plate this week i can't wait to see
what you find from this episode
uh and that's gonna come out on the
channel tomorrow so keep a lookout for
that follow me at avos follow mt at
mastertainment follow new rockstars
subscribe to inside marvel wherever you
get your podcasts thank you for watching
and we'll close with our favorite moment
of the episode hey
hey
if we could miniaturize an arc reactor
oh that's a dumb idea
[Music]
you